ich bin über das gehäuse wenig
mittlerweile jeder wissen freunde und
deswegen habe ich auch vor einiger zeit
hat sie mich gefragt hey jude was ist
eigentlich das teuerste produkt von
gucci einer übertriebenen luxus
komischen marke ich habe dazu ein video
über den kanal hochgeladen und habe
gesehen dass es dort dekorationsartikel
für 25.000 euro gibt es gibt
frauenbekleidung die ab 5000 euro das
teuerste herren stück ist eine jacke für
5800 euro das allerletzte verehrten 5800
in diesem video wer kann da habe ich
dann gesagt hey leute wenn ihr
hunderttausend landschaft gestellt ich
mir diese jacke das video über 120.000
leid dass ich wieder zurück im kader ist
das ziel klar bin ich wollte mit der
post an eine riesiges paket ist es
einfach eine gottverdammte jacke kommt
deutschland
ich hätte dieses paket einfach ist bevor
allerdings gehen wie man sich in die
kommentare schreibt weil das war unter
dem video auch unfassbar heute vertreten
der momentan 5800 euro für die akte kann
dort rentenalter stellen diese jacke
nicht behalten
findet die tatsächlich auch über das
hässlich leib bitte bis zum ende des
videos dran freuen
normalerweise kann man das in
sondergrößen umgestellter zwischenzeit
gegen den pc oder
einen sprung becken oder keine ahnung
was aber die leute eine skizze die ihr
sind die audi r8 unzählige things habt
ihr leider antwortete sie ich fühle mich
wie diese ganzen blogger mädels dann da
willst du dich die stadt laporte
hier ist wirklich unzählige von dieser
folie 320 nein es geht sind wir unten
einen brief vom kutscherin da steht
einfach meine zahlung informationen
neben diesen großen briefumschlag hat
mir dann auch seinen kleinen
briefumschlag hier bitten da steht drauf
wir freuen sich bald wieder bei in
qigong zu begrüßen
i don't think so ich brauche die
tatsächlich auch nicht da haben wir
unten tatsächlich dort eine hütte
wahrscheinlich konnte schon 1000 euro
die tüte brauchen wir tatsächlich auch
nicht dass es kommt auch wieder einen
kombi körperlosen das hier
ich bin ich muss eigentlich richtig
frostig sein wenn sie noch zurück sendet
also ich weiß nicht ob überhaupt
irgendjemand außer zweifel gedacht hat
dass diese jacke behalten werden
hast du überhaupt nicht zu meinen style
aber vielleicht kann ich theoretisch
gleich versuchen ausländer
zusammenzustellen auf jeden fall
beschäftigen uns jetzt in diesem paket
frage dass man einfach schnell jetzt in
1000 gemeinden und heißen brei so das
haben sie jetzt die ausrüstung geht von
gutschein- bonus- meine damen und herren
das hier ist die 5800 euro hätten ihr
habt ihr das neueste buch von loki dass
ich nicht wirklich gestellt habe es muss
halt sagen für 5800 euro bekommen war
schon ein highlight das werde ich das
irgendwie mit bestellungen von anderen
webseiten verbreitet so mein gott ist
die hässliche es geht schon toll
kraftakt das geht schon auch verschickt
also die muslime und innerhalb von zwei
tagen ist dass die anderen kommen als
megatrend das hier meine damen und
herren ist es das teuerste produkt ist
das ist das echte 5800 euro
ich weiß es nicht man muss natürlich
dazu sei es wert der reißverschluss und
ich liebe dich ich muss dazu sagen nein
das ist nicht wahr
wenn ich das mache kann ich dir noch
zurückschicken ja bestimmt ein paar
sekunden später
bitte nicht entfernen dieses etikett
muss vor rückgabe und umtausch befestigt
bleiben die haben das hier so darum
gemacht den bügel mit diesen dingen das
kriegt man nicht ab ich wollte ein setzt
diese jacke mal anprobieren
aber das geht nicht ich darf das ding
nicht entfernen sonst kann ich sie nicht
mehr zurückgeben
naja gut erzählt jetzt mit bügel an sich
endlich mal breit
ich kriege ja für mich wieder voll da
[Musik]
würde das teuerste produkt auf ganze
gucci herrenbekleidung 5800 euro leder
keine ahnung was sie anzieht für mich
aus die sonne die sonne jacke mit der
oper dann doch in den garten gehe ich
keine ahnung also ich weiß nicht es
sieht jetzt natürlich auch scheiße aus
dem hügel wir aber ich will das geld
wirklich noch zurückstellen weil 5800
euro falle jahre alter dafür könnte ich
mir den ganzen kleiderschrank kaufen
also nicht nur die kleider hat sondern
auch noch den schrank ich weiß nicht was
haltet ihr von erste umfrage findet ihr
sie hässlich oder hässlich beantwortet
wir doch gern mal ja leute so sieht nun
reisen die akte aus so von vorne wie
gesagt von innen gegen die miezen glaube
ich weiß nicht warum
so auch jetzt schon ausziehen
nein es ist hätte ich das 5800 euro
etikett
ich hoffe es ist alles nie gegangen mit
dem etikett ist muss aber einen noch
alles dran sein dass es deutlich werde
dass dinge die der verpacken und
natürlich zurückstecken sagt coach ihr
einfach das ist mein
und an meinem pc erstellt daraus
versehen eigentlich wollte ich noch
sonst einen versuchen damit zu kriegen
ich habe hier unten noch zur schule die
würden eventuell wird noch ein bisschen
dazu passen die nach ist allerdings
damit wirklich nicht so zum affen machen
jetzt kommt ihr hier natürlich auch
wieder schön verpackt songwriter mit der
nächste der die sich bestellt er
übrigens echt beschissen geschmack der
nächste der sich die eventuell gestellt
wir die dann natürlich komplett neue
fabrik wie gesagt eine an mit dem gürtel
mit dem gürtel wahrscheinlich hier ist
jetzt auf jeden fall eingebracht haben
diese auftragsbestätigung im rechnungs
kaffee muss jetzt auch wenn das ganze so
ständen werde sagte es allerdings freute
ich hätte ich nie gedacht dass
irgendjemand überhaupt vermutet dass
sich die jacke wirklich behalte und mir
im kleiderschrank hängen heute
allerdings habe ich mir das gedacht wie
auch leute 5800 euro für eine jacke das
nächste mega kratzig schicke ich auf
jeden fall zurück das ist ein unfassbar
großer haufen geld ich habe mir damals
gedacht dass ich ein zehntel dieser
jacke also was bei der jagd
wahrscheinlich so ein stückchen vom arm
wäre 580 euro möchte ich spende an die
malteser denn wirklich eine menge menge
menschen in deutschland auch in köln und
auch viele kinder die sich überhaupt
nicht ab und an vielleicht eine neue
jacke leisten können oder ein t shirt
oder überhaupt auch genug geld für essen
et cetera haben 580 euro einmalig
spenden
vielen dank später wurde getätigt
wie gesagt zum letzten video ein
bisschen eskaliert sei es mit dem
leichten andererseits wird ihr nicht
gedacht dass das teuerste produkt
wirklich für herrenbekleidung 5800 euro
ich meine wer welcher mensch kauft sich
denn so was passiert ist auf jeden fall
wiederkommen ich weiß nicht heirate das
produkt verhält die jacke hatte die
behalten was euro teuerster liegen
aktuell keine ahnung schreibt gerne in
die kommentare ich habe ich den
maltesern und in die beschreibung
geparkt haben etwas spenden möchte ich
meine auch eine euro hilft auf jeden
fall
ich werde die sache jetzt zum ostring
und direkt zurück sein ich hoffe das
geht noch sollte das ganze dann auch mal
mit louis vuitton machen oder mit apple
oder keine ahnung was schreiben wir das
unternehmen die kommentare wo ich auch
mal nach dem teuersten oder vielleicht
günstigsten gucken soll das gleich
dauern
[Musik]